This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is part 2 of the 2017-2018 mini-stories episodes, where I interview the staff and our collaborators about their favorite little design stories that don't quite fill out an entire episode for whatever reason, but they are cool 99PI stories nonetheless. We have underground tunnels, alarms, mysterious filing cabinets, and gold. Tiny, tiny amounts of gold. Prepare to be very interesting at your next party. Let's do this.
这里是 99% 隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这是 2017-2018 年迷你故事集的第二部分，在这一期里，我采访了工作人员和我们的合作者，听他们分享自己最喜欢的那些简短的设计故事。无论出于什么原因，这些故事可能不足以撑起整整一期节目，但它们依然是很酷的 99PI 故事。我们有地下隧道、警报器、神秘的文件柜，还有黄金。微乎其微的黄金。准备好在你的下一次派对上让人刮目相看吧。我们开始吧。
Why don't you start with who you are, actually? Okay, yeah, so I am Delaney Hall and I am a producer and senior editor on staff. All right. So what is your story today? Well, first I'm going to introduce you to Peter Sucalowski. And my levels are okay. Okay. So I'm not too loud. I'm not pop. I try to not pop my peas, but I get excited. I'll try not to talk too fast. I get excited. I'll try not to talk too fast. And the stuff that Peter gets really excited about, the stuff that makes him pop his piece and talk really fast is language because he's the editor at large at Miriam Webster and he's a lexicographer. Lexicographer is a person who compiles and edits dictionaries. That's the old definition,
你为什么不先介绍一下你自己呢？好吧，好的，我是德莱尼·霍尔，我是团队的一名制作人兼资深编辑。好的。那么你今天带来的故事是什么？嗯，首先我要向你介绍彼得·苏卡洛斯基。我的收音音量正常吧。好吧。所以我声音不会太大。我没有爆破音。我尽量不发出爆破音，但我太兴奋了。我尽量语速不要太快。我太兴奋了。我尽量语速不要太快。而彼得真正兴奋的事情，让他发出爆破音并且语速飞快的事情就是语言，因为他是韦氏词典的特约编辑，他是一名词典编纂者。词典编纂者就是收集和编辑词典的人。那是旧的定义，
A person who compiles and edits dictionaries, that's the old definition, the great Samuel Johnson, the lexicographer in London in the mid-18th century, very famously defined a lexicographer as a harmless drudge. And Peter actually said that they use that term affectionately now as like a kind of badge of honor. They like to be called harmless drudges, so don't worry about insulting them if if you want to use that term. So what is a harmless judge like Peter do all day at Mary and Webster? Well
收集和编辑词典的人，那是旧的定义，18世纪中期伦敦伟大的词典编纂者塞缪尔·约翰逊曾非常著名地将词典编纂者定义为“无害的苦工”。而彼得实际上说过，他们现在很亲切地使用这个词，把它当成一种荣誉的象征。他们喜欢被称为“无害的苦工”，所以如果你想用这个词，不用担心会冒犯他们。那么像彼得这样无害的苦工在韦氏词典里整天都做些什么呢？嗯，
from his description it sounds like they work in an office that is very very quiet, silent basically and it's filled with these massive steel filing cabinets and And I've kind of been imagining it like that scene in Raiders of the Lost Ark at the end where the man is pushing that crate through a huge warehouse. But instead of stacks of enormous crates, it's filled with metal filing cabinets. And those metal filing cabinets are filled with index cards.
从他的描述听起来，他们在一个非常非常安静的办公室里工作，基本上是无声的，里面摆满了巨大的钢制文件柜。我一直在想象它就像《夺宝奇兵》结尾的那个场景，那个人把一个板条箱推过一个巨大的仓库。但里面堆的不是巨大的板条箱，而是装满了金属文件柜。而那些金属文件柜里装满了索引卡片。
As far as I know, it's the largest body of collected evidence of any language in the world. It's 15 or 16 million index cards with a word in use, that is to say, in context, with its full bibliography. So we know who wrote it and where it was published and when it was published. And so that is the work of lexicographers. They're the keepers of that word history. And for a long time, before computers came along, this is how they did it with these massive systems
据我所知，这是世界上所有语言中收集到的最大规模的证据文集。这里有 1500 万或 1600 万张索引卡片，记录着使用中的单词，也就是说，在语境中，带有完整的参考书目。所以我们知道是谁写的、在哪里出版的以及是什么时候出版的。这就是词典编纂者的工作。他们是这些词语历史的守护者。在很长一段时间里，在电脑出现之前，这就是他们使用这些庞大系统的方式——
of filing cabinets. There's the file for the phonetician, for the pronunciation editor. There's the file for our dating editors who do the etymological dating. So it's a place full of file cabinets. But this isn't actually a story about how the Miriam Webster offices are filled with filing cabinets. It's not, okay.
文件柜系统。这里有语音学家的文件，供发音编辑使用。这里有为我们做词源年代测定的年代编辑准备的文件。所以这是一个摆满了文件柜的地方。但这其实并不是一个关于韦氏词典办公室里到处都是文件柜的故事。不是的，好吧。
No, it's not. It's a story about one special filing cabinet in their office. Okay, so here's where it gets really interesting. So one day Peter was wandering through these endless rows of filing cabinets and he came across this one. And one of them simply said backward index on it. And so he opens up the cabinet that says backward index. And I realized what it was, which was all of the headwords of the Unabridged Dictionary, some 315,000 separate index cards with only one word on them.
不，不是的。这是一个关于他们办公室里一个特殊文件柜的故事。好吧，这里就是真正有趣的地方。所以有一天，彼得在这些一望无际的文件柜行列中漫步，他遇到了这个。其中一个上面简单地写着“反向索引”。于是他打开写着“反向索引”的文件柜。我意识到那是什么，那是《全本词典》的所有字头，大约有 31.5 万张独立的索引卡片，每张卡片上只有一个词。
And it was a head word typed backwards. And so the head word is the entry in the dictionary. That's the first word. That's the word in question. Right. Yeah, exactly. So this index is like, imagine all the words in the dictionary, but typed backwards and then organized alphabetically.
而且这个字头是倒过来拼写的。字头就是词典里的词条。那是第一个词。也就是我们要讨论的词。对的。没错，确实如此。所以这个索引就像是，想象一下词典里的所有单词，但是把它们倒过来拼写，然后按字母顺序排列。
Okay. Okay. So why would you do that? Yeah, that is the question, because the utility of it is not immediately obvious, at least not to non-lexicographers like you and me, but Peter, the harmless dredge, he kind of got it. Lexicography is an extreme sport. This is a kind of a radical practice of collection and of archiving.
好吧。好吧。那为什么要这么做呢？是的，这就是问题所在，因为它的实用性并不是一眼就能看出来的，至少对你我这样的非词典编纂者来说是这样，但彼得这个无害的苦工，他有点明白了。词典编纂是一项极限运动。这是一种激进的收集和归档实践。
And so to a certain degree, this is maybe the weirdest example of that kind of archiving, but it made a kind of sense to me. And to really understand why it makes any kind of sense, you have to think back to when Lexicographers first started compiling the backward index, which was in the 1930s, it turns out, which was a time before computers and all of the search possibilities that they allow. In the pre-digital era, how else could we have known that there are, for example, 500
所以在某种程度上，这也许是这种归档方式中最奇怪的例子，但对我来说它确实有某种意义。要真正理解为什么它有意义，你必须回想一下词典编纂者最初开始编纂反向索引的时候，原来是在 20 世纪 30 年代，那是一个还没有电脑以及它们所带来的所有搜索功能的年代。在数码时代之前，我们怎么可能知道，比如说，
words in the dictionary that end in allogy? Yeah, you're getting it. That's because with a regular dictionary, just organized in a regular alphabetical way, a word like ecology would not appear next to a word like technology because one starts with E and one starts with D. Oh my God, it okay. So with the backward index, all the words that end in allogy, for example, would be grouped together.
词典里有 500 个以 ology 结尾的单词？是的，你懂了。这是因为在普通词典中，仅仅按照常规的字母顺序排列，像 ecology（生态学）这样的词就不会和 technology（技术）这样的词挨在一起，因为一个以 E 开头，一个以 T 开头。哦天哪，好吧。所以有了反向索引，所有以 ology 结尾的单词，例如，都会被归类在一起。
Yeah. So you couldn't actually look up allogy words. You would look up YG-O-L-O-O-Word. Okay. But you do in that, you would find them. Exactly. Yeah. So cool.
是的。所以你实际上不能直接查 “ology” 结尾的词。你会去查 “yg-o-l-o-o” 开头的词。好吧。但通过这种方式，你会找到它们的。完全正确。太酷了。
Kind of kind of ingenious. And there are actually a lot of other examples of why this is useful. But you do in that you would find them. Exactly. Yeah. So cool. Kind of ingenious. And there are actually a lot of other examples of why this is useful. There was no way that they could know, for example, how many words in English are made with the compound like, like, you know, block like, clock like, rock like, sock like, chalk like, or how many open compounds that is to say two word phrases that use pony, so highland pony, Shetland pony, Welsh pony, that kind of thing.
有点……有点巧妙。其实还有很多其他例子可以说明为什么这很有用。但通过这种方式，你会找到它们的。完全正确。太酷了。有点……有点巧妙。其实还有很多其他例子可以说明为什么这很有用。以前他们根本不可能知道，比如说，英语中有多少个单词是用 like 这样的复合词构成的，你知道的，block like（像方块的）、clock like（像时钟的）、rock like（像岩石的）、sock like（像袜子的）、chalk like（像粉笔的），或者有多少个开放式复合词，也就是使用 pony（小马）的两词短语，比如 highland pony（高地小马）、Shetland pony（设得兰小马）、Welsh pony（威尔士小马）之类的那种。
And then it gets a little deeper, those words that are related morphologically, like ethylogical, lithological, ornithological, you know, things that end in that particular sequence of letters. And then just basic rhyming sequences, steepy weepy, sweepy, 40, shorty, snorty. And in fact, this backward index was instrumental in the creation of Miriam Webster's first rhyming dictionary.
然后这就更深入了一点，那些在形态上相关的词，比如 ethylological（乙基逻辑的）、lithological（岩性学的）、ornithological（鸟类学的），你知道的，以特定字母顺序结尾的东西。然后还有基本的押韵序列，steepy、weepy、sweepy，40、shorty、snorty。事实上，这个反向索引对于韦氏词典第一本押韵词典的问世起到了关键作用。
Oh, yeah, I have one of those. Oh, yeah, yeah, they're very popular. They're really, really good. So by reading words backwards, you can start to see new kinds of patterns, like theology pattern or the logical pattern or just rhyming patterns. That's so cool. The kind of lexical detail that we can get into by looking at the language backwards does sort of illuminate our knowledge of the language as we read it in a normal way.
哦，对，我有一本那个。哦，对，对，它们非常受欢迎。它们真的非常好。所以通过倒着读单词，你可以开始发现新型的模式，比如 theology 模式、ological 模式，或者单纯的押韵模式。太酷了。通过倒着看语言所能获得的这种词汇细节，确实照亮了我们以正常方式阅读语言时的知识。
So you said it came from the 1930s before the computers, but does Peter know anything about who actually made this mysterious fall in cabinet? Yeah, so after he discovered it, he started doing some research. And exactly who invented it is still a bit of a mystery. He figured out that it dates back to the 1930s and there's some evidence that lexicographers worked on it up until the 1970s.
所以你刚才说它来自 20 世纪 30 年代，在电脑出现之前，但彼得知道是谁制作了这个神秘的文件柜吗？是的，在他发现它之后，他开始做一些研究。究竟是谁发明了它仍然是个谜。他发现它最早可以追溯到 20 世纪 30 年代，有证据表明词典编纂者一直工作到 20 世纪 70 年代都在使用它。
So he knows how long it was actively being compiled. And he also found out that the project was a kind of favorite pet project of this one editor named Philip Gove. He edited Webster's third unabridged dictionary in the 1950s, and it sounds like he was very rigorous and rule-oriented. Who is sort of famous for his organizational skills and for making the dictionary apparatus, that is to say, the things that we use as kind of code in the dictionary, things like, you know, what does a bold-faced colon mean, What does a light-faced, you know, italic, semi-colon mean? When can we use commas?
所以他知道它被积极编纂了多久。他还发现这个项目是一个名叫菲利普·古夫（Philip Gove）的编辑最喜欢的心头好。他在 20 世纪 50 年代编辑了《韦氏第三版新国际词典》，听起来他非常严谨、讲究规矩。他因其组织能力和制定词典体系而闻名，也就是我们在词典中用作某种代码的东西，比如，加粗的冒号是什么意思，细体的斜体分号是什么意思？我们什么时候可以使用逗号？
So there's a rule for everything. And so it was really gov who systematized all of that. He made a rule book for us, for the editors, that was followed to the T. It was really, really strict and very kind of innovative in its way, and also kind of proto-digital, because when we finally did digitize that dictionary, we recognized how very regular the apparatus was. So Gove, from Peter's description, it seems like he thought about the dictionary with the logic of a computer programmer, but before computers were a thing.
所以凡事都有规则。因此，真正将所有这些系统化的人正是古夫。他为我们这些编辑制定了一本必须严格遵守的规则手册。它真的非常非常严格，并且以其独特的方式具有创新性，同时也带有一种准数码时代的特征，因为当我们最终将那本词典数字化时，我们意识到这个体系是多么的规律。所以从彼得的描述来看，古夫似乎是以计算机程序员的逻辑来思考词典的，而且是在计算机还没出现的年代。
And now that computers are a thing, I mean, you mentioned the background index sort of fell out in the 1970s, which makes tons of sense. The computers must have really changed the way lexiconfers or the dictionary really works. Yeah, totally. I mean, for one thing, they have made the old school backwards index totally obsolete on the Merriam Webster website. There's an advanced search function where you can type inology or phobia. You don't have to spell it backwards. It pulls up all the words that end withology or phobia.
既然现在有了计算机，我的意思是，你提到反向索引在 20 世纪 70 年代左右被淘汰了，这完全说得通。计算机一定彻底改变了词典编纂者或词典的工作方式。完全是这样。我的意思是，一方面，它们让老式的反向索引在韦氏词典网站上完全过时了。韦氏词典网站上有一个高级搜索功能，你可以在其中输入 ology 或 phobia。你不需要倒着拼写。它会调出所有以 ology 或 phobia 结尾的单词。
So easy. We have it so easy. We really do. We really do. And then computers have also allowed lexicographers like Peter to see other kinds of interesting patterns. For example. Well, my favorite that we talked about in this interview is this function on Miriam Webster's website, which is called Time Traveler.
太简单了。我们太轻松了。确实如此。真的。然后计算机还允许像彼得这样的词典编纂者看到其他类型有趣模式。例如。嗯，我们在这次采访中谈到的我最喜欢的功能是韦氏词典网站上的一个功能，叫做“时间旅行者”。
By which you can reorder the dictionary in chronological order, as opposed to alphabetical order, because ultimately alphabetical order is random. It's arbitrary. But chronological order isn't, because English develops in a very particular way. All the words, for example, about train travel, and train tracks, and coal, and engines, they all come at a certain time, all words that have to do with repeating firearms. They all come at a certain time, you know, the words that entered the language regarding the law that are derived from French. They all come in at a similar time. So reorganizing the dictionary in a digital way turns out to be a way to sort of turn the dictionary into a three-dimensional Turns out to be a way to sort of turn the dictionary into a three-dimensional search.
通过这个功能，你可以按时间顺序列出词典，而不是按字母顺序，因为归根结底字母顺序是随机的。它是随意的。但时间顺序不是，因为英语的发展有着非常独特的方式。例如，所有关于火车旅行、铁道、煤炭和发动机的单词，它们都在某个特定时间出现；所有与连发火器有关的单词；它们都在某个特定时间出现，你知道的，语言中关于法律的、源自法语的单词。它们都在相似的时间出现。事实证明，以数字化的方式重新组织词典，是一种将词典变成三维搜索的方法。
Rather than just simply a list, we can go in greater depth. That's amazing. That's so cool. I love the idea of the time traveler. Yeah, it's such a good way to order knowledge in a certain way. And it's sort of like the backwards index was an early pre-digital attempt at achieving that kind of three-dimensional search. Right. That's so cool. Oh, thanks.
我们不仅仅是在看一个简单的列表，而是可以进行更深入的探究。太惊人了。太酷了。我喜欢时间旅行者的这个想法。是的，这真是一种按特定方式组织知识的好方法。这有点像反向索引是实现这种三维搜索的早期前数字时代的尝试。没错。太酷了。哦，谢谢。
Yeah, thank you. We got to know Vivian Lee when she was a finalist in the radiotopia podcast contest. Her show Villain-ish is premiering this year, but she's also going to do a couple of 99 PI stories for us, including this one, a mini story, and she decided to start big. So I want to start with the worst nuclear accident in US history. Goodness, okay, go ahead. For many years, there has been a vigorous debate in this country about the safety of the nation's 72 nuclear energy power plants.
好的，谢谢你。我们是通过维维安·李（Vivian Lee）在成为电台乌托邦播客大赛决赛选手时认识她的。她的节目《恶棍秀》（Villain-ish）今年首播，但她也将为我们制作几个 99 PI 故事，包括这个迷你故事，她决定从一个大题材开始。所以我想从美国历史上最严重的核事故开始。好吧，请讲。多年来，这个国家一直在激烈辩论全国 72 座核电站的安全性。
That debate is likely to be intensified because of what happened early this morning at a nuclear power plant in Pennsylvania. Max? So, you probably heard about this before because of big news, but back in 1979, there was a partial core meltdown at the three-mile island nuclear power plant near Harrisburg, Pennsylvania. A cooling pump broke down, and the plant did just what it was supposed to do. Shut it's all hard. But not before some radioactivity had escaped.
由于今天早晨宾夕法尼亚州一座核电站发生的事情，这场争论可能会加剧。马克思？所以，你可能之前因为重大新闻听说过这个，但在 1979 年，宾夕法尼亚州哈里斯堡附近的“三哩岛”核电站发生了一次堆芯部分熔毁事故。一个冷却泵坏了，而电厂的反应跟设计完全一样——紧急停堆了。但在一些放射性物质泄漏之前。
We had two reports. A bunch of communities around the reactor ended up having to evacuate and it just freaked a lot of people out. Well, they should have been freaked out. That was freaking scary. So in the aftermath of what happened, the president ordered a commission to investigate what happened, and there was this big post-mortem report to try to understand what had gone wrong. And what actually did go wrong? Well, it was kind of complicated because a lot of things went wrong. Well, it was kind of complicated because a lot of things went wrong. But three mile,
我们收到了两份报告。反应堆周围的一堆社区最终不得不疏散，这吓坏了很多人。嗯，他们确实该被吓坏了。那真是吓死人了。所以在事件发生后，总统下令成立一个委员会来调查发生了什么，并且有一份大型的事故总结报告，试图弄清楚究竟哪里出了问题。那究竟是什么出了问题呢？嗯，这有点复杂，因为很多事情都出了问题。嗯，这有点复杂，因为很多事情都出了问题。但三哩岛，
three mile island was a classic cascading failure type accident. So essentially, a relief felv in one of the reactious got stuck in the open position, which caused all the coolant to be released. So the coolant ran out of the core and it started to overheat. And in the end, it ended up being a pretty minor mechanical breakdown. But what they found out was that it was actually human error that made the whole situation worse. Humans make everything worse. They really do. They really do.
三哩岛是一起典型的级联失效型事故。基本上，其中一个反应堆的一个泄压阀卡在了开启位置，导致所有冷却剂都泄漏了。所以冷却剂从堆芯中流失，它开始过热。最后，这其实只是一次相当轻微的机械故障。但他们发现，真正让整个情况恶化的是人为错误。人类让一切变得更糟糕。确实如此。真的。
A cascading failure of humans. But the plant operators could see and they could hear that something was wrong because all these lights are flashing and alarms are sounding, but it wasn't clear exactly what was wrong because all the alarms were really confusing and just made the situation worse. Because they went off all the same time, that would have hindered communication at the very time when they needed to communicate. And who is that? So that's Judy Edworthy.
人类的级联失效。但电厂操作员可以看到也听到有东西出问题了，因为所有的灯都在闪烁，警报器也在鸣响，但并不清楚究竟哪里出了问题，因为所有的警报声都非常混乱，反而让情况变得更糟。因为它们同时响起，这会在他们最需要沟通的时候阻碍沟通。那是谁？那是朱迪·埃德沃西（Judy Edworthy）。
She studies psychochoustics and alarm design at the University of Plymouth. And she told me that Three Mile Island is actually a really common case study when it comes to bad and ineffective alarm design. Three Mile Island is very well known for having hundreds of alarms going off in a very short period of time. Now, that's an example where there was no alarm philosophy, because that shouldn't have happened. So alarm design really matters? Yes, it definitely matters. And there have actually been other major accidents where alarms that were supposed to help people respond to emergency, but instead they made the situation worse.
她在普利茅斯大学研究心理声学和警报设计。她告诉我，在糟糕且无效的警报设计方面，三哩岛其实是一个非常常见的案例研究。三哩岛因在极短时间内响起数百个警报而闻名。现在，这是一个没有警报哲学的例子，因为那本不应该发生。所以警报设计真的很重要吗？是的，绝对重要。事实上，还发生过其他重大事故，本应帮助人们应对紧急情况的警报，反而让情况变得更糟。
Like the Deepwater Horizon accident in 2010, which caused a ton of oil to spill into the Gulf of Mexico. I didn't know that I had anything to do with my alarm failure. Oh, yeah, yeah. It turned out that a bunch of the alarm systems on the deep water rig had actually been inhibited for at least a year before the accidents happened because Trans Ocean, which is the company that ran the rig, didn't want false alarms to wake up the crew while they were sleeping. So the alarms were too easily triggered, and so they just turned them off so they didn't
比如 2010 年的“深水地平线”事故，导致大量石油流入墨西哥湾。我不知道这跟我的警报失效有什么关系。哦，对，对。事实证明，在事故发生前至少一年，深水钻井平台上的许多警报系统实际上都被禁用了，因为运营该钻井平台的公司越洋钻探（TransOcean）不希望假警报在船员睡觉时吵醒他们。所以警报太容易被触发了，于是他们干脆把它们关掉，这样就不会
upset the operation of the rig. Yeah, exactly. False alarms in-dram basically. So this is the kind of stuff that Professor Edward thinks about a lot. Yes, she thinks about the best ways to design alarms so that they can accomplish what they need to do. And one of her big concerns is that humans are just bombarded by so many alarms in our everyday life that we just start tuning them out.
打扰钻井平台的作业了。是的，完全正确。基本上就是虚假警报导致了麻木。所以这就是爱德华兹教授经常思考的问题。是的，她思考的是如何最好地设计警报，以便它们能够完成需要做的事情。她最担忧的事情之一是，人类在日常生活中被太多的警报狂轰滥炸，以至于我们开始对它们充耳不闻。
Or turning them off. Yeah, because I think the whole world's selfish of a long fatigue, because I think we're just so used to, alarms just going on all the time. And they're almost, they're just a backdrop to our lives. She says that the average person probably hears about 100 different types of alarms a day. They're just all the time you stand at a cash register and it's beeping away and it's a, and then you
或者干脆把它们关掉。对，因为我认为整个世界都在遭受警报疲劳的折磨，因为我认为我们太习惯警报一直响个不停了。它们几乎成了我们生活的背景音。她说，普通人一天大概能听到大约 100 种不同类型的警报。它们无时无刻不在，你站在收银机前，它在哔哔作响，然后你
hear cars, car alarms going off and you've got microwaves and you've got everything beeps. And for no good reason, quite a lot of the time. And so people just start tuning them out and they lose track of which alarms are important and which ones aren't. If everything in the world is beeping, we kind of forget that those beeps are trying to point out actual problems. But another consideration is that alarm tones themselves should communicate something about what the problem is.
听到汽车警报声在响，你家里有微波炉，什么东西都在哔哔叫。而且很多时候根本没有充分的理由。于是人们开始对它们充耳不闻，并且分不清哪些警报重要，哪些不重要。如果世界上的每样东西都在哔哔叫，我们就会忘记这些哔哔声其实是在试图指出真正的问题。但另一个考虑是，警报音本身应该传达一些关于问题所在的信息。
And so how does that work? Okay. So, when you think of an alarm sound, what do you think of? Well, I think of a bracing, clacks-on, beeping, siren, high-pitched, shrill alarming, upsetting. Yes, yes, exactly. So we basically all have one cultural reference point for what an alarm should sound like.
那这该怎么运作呢？好的。所以，当你想到警报声时，你会想到什么？嗯，我想到了刺耳的、防空警报式的、哔哔声的、尖叫的、高音调的、尖锐刺耳的、令人不安的声音。是的，是的，完全正确。所以我们基本上都有一个文化参照点，那就是警报应该听起来是什么样的。
And that's because in the olden days, we didn't really have much range in terms of alarm mechanisms. In the past, alarms, you could only make an alarm by are this pushing sand, pushing air through an object, In the past, alarms, you could only make an alarm by, are this pushing sand, pushing air through an object like a claxon, or by hitting something like a bell? We associate these archaic noises like bells and whistles
那是因为在过去，就警报机制而言，我们的选择范围并不大。在过去，你只能通过……将沙子推过某个物体、将空气通过某个物体（比如汽笛）来制造警报，或者通过敲击某种东西（比如钟）来制造警报。我们将这些古老的噪音（如钟声、口哨声、
and sirens and claxons with auditory alarms because that's just what the technology at the time allowed for and we got used to it. So Judy made actually this kind of funny point which is that we have such a narrow idea of what an alarm should sound like that it even shows up in futuristic sci-fi movies. Alright, sci-fi films, all sorts of wonderful things
警笛和汽笛）与声音警报联系在一起，因为这正是当时的技术所允许的，而我们也习惯了。所以朱迪提出了一个非常有趣的观点，那就是我们对警报听起来应该是什么样子的想象是如此狭隘，以至于它甚至出现在了富有未来感的科幻电影中。好吧，科幻电影，在电影里会发生各种各样美妙的事情。
happen in the film. But when you, but alarms go off and they're just the same alarms that we're just used to. And it's like come in the the film The Martian, right? They can do all these wonderful things in good Mars, but they can't design better alarms and we've got now. That's a lot of alarm sounds. Yeah. Or lirty.
但当警报响起时，它们依然是我们已经习惯的那些普通警报。这就像在电影《火星救援》里一样，对吧？他们在火星上可以做所有这些了不起的事情，但他们却设计不出比我们现在更好的警报。那是相当多的警报声。是的。或者警笛声。
And they all kind of sound the same. They guys in trouble. Yeah. To fully. But yeah, but with digital sound, you know, so much more as possible, you can make an alarm sound like basically anything. You can use music. Some people use tones or sequences or melodies.
而且它们听起来都差不多。他们遇到麻烦了。是的。完全是这样。但是，有了数字声音，你知道，可能性要大得多，你可以让警报听起来像基本上任何东西。你可以用音乐。有些人使用音调、序列或旋律。
You can use sounds that are the sounds of real objects or real things. And we tend to refer to these as auditory icons, but really they're just metaphors. And I love this. I love the idea of auditory icons, but really they're just metaphors. And I love this. I love the idea of auditory icons and metaphorical sounds. It's just really interesting and cool to me. So what's a good example of an auditory icon? Okay, so hospitals are notorious for having these terrible soundscapes because
你可以使用真实物体或真实事物的声音。我们倾向于称这些为听觉图标，但实际上它们只是隐喻。我喜欢这个。我喜欢听觉图标的想法。我喜欢听觉图标和隐喻声音的想法。这对我来说真的很有趣也很酷。那么听觉图标的一个好例子是什么？好的，医院以拥有这些可怕的声音景观而闻名，因为
they share a amount of alarms that are just constantly going off and like at all hours of the night. And they're all just beeps and tones that are kind of variations of each other. So Judy designed this new tone that's meant to be used when there's a problem related to a patient's medication and this is how it works. What you might do is you put an ounce in a lamp by using something like this to get your attention, not followed by. See? Yeah, I mean, it's that's interesting.
它们充斥着不断响起的警报声，而且在夜间的任何时间都在响。它们都只是哔哔声和音调，某种程度上是彼此的变体。所以朱迪设计了一种新的音调，旨在用于与患者用药有关的问题出现时，它是这样运作的。你可以做的是，通过使用类似这样的东西发出提示来吸引你的注意，而不是……看？是的，我的意思是，这很有趣。
So there's a little bit of a, a, a, a tangent graver and then something metaphorical. So you can really tell what it is. Right. The sound of the pill bottle kind of cues medication in your head. So you kind of already know what the problem is before you even address it. What we find with these auditory icons is that they're very, very easy to learn. You just tell people once what they mean, and then they're away. They've understood it. So instead of some generic and alarming alarm sound that could literally mean anything, which is what happened at Three Mile Island, you can imagine these auditory icons that kind of communicate exactly what the problem is. So there wouldn't be this confusion
所以有一点点切线，然后是一些隐喻性的东西。这样你就能真正分辨出它是什么。没错。药瓶的声音在你的脑海中暗示了药物。所以在你处理问题之前，你其实就已经知道问题是什么了。我们发现这些听觉图标非常非常容易学习。你只需要告诉人们一次它们意味着什么，然后他们就明白了。因此，不用那种字面意思可能代表任何事的通用且吓人的警报声（就像三哩岛发生的那样），你可以想象这些听觉图标能够准确地传达问题所在。所以就不会存在
about trying to decipher what this one tone means. Except for a Three Mile Island, when there was a hundred things going wrong, it would sound like a preschool classroom. Oh, that is so. Sounds amazing. That is so. That is so.
试图解读这一个音调到底意味着什么的困惑。除非在三哩岛，当有一百件事情同时出事时，那听起来就像是一个学前班教室。哦，太棒了。听起来太棒了。真是这样。真是这样。
But that becomes the sound design challenge of like how do you preference which one you hear the loudest and in what order do you hear them and sound design challenge of like, how do you preference which one you hear the loudest and in what order do you hear them and all that sort of thing, which you know, is really a cool concept to begin to tackle. Yeah, yeah, you basically have to rethink an environment from the top down in terms of what it sounds like. Well, cool. Well, thank you so much.
但这成为了声音设计的挑战，比如你如何优先决定听到哪个声音最大声，以及你以什么顺序听到它们，诸如此类的事情，你知道，这真的是一个开始着手解决的酷炫概念。是的，是的，你基本上必须从上到下重新构思一个环境的声音。太酷了。好的，非常感谢。
No, thank you. Since your voice isn't heard as much on the air, why don't you say who you are? Cool. I'm Shreef Yusuf. I am... What did you settle on? Technical producer. Technical producer. Yeah, technical producer for the show,
不，谢谢。既然你在节目里没有那么多声音，你为什么不自我介绍一下呢？酷。我是谢里夫·优素福（Shreef Yusuf）。我是……你最后决定叫什么来着？技术制作人。技术制作人。是的，节目的技术制作人，
which basically means I try to make things sound good. That's awesome. And you do make things sound good. Nice. So what kind of story do you have for us today? I have, I believe it's called a mini story. And it is about alchemy. Woo!
这基本上意味着我努力让声音听起来不错。太棒了。而且你确实让声音听起来不错。很好。那么你今天给我们带来了什么样的故事？我有，我相信它被称为迷你故事。它是关于炼金术的。噢！
Alchemy. Yeah, I know what alchemy is. Yeah, what is it? It is the idea of using chemistry to turn lead into gold. Yeah, basically, or any other base metal. It was this loony idea that folks in the medieval ages were obsessed with turning base metals like lead or mercury into gold, which of course is preposterous nowadays.
炼金术。是的，我知道什么是炼金术。是的，那是什么？这是利用化学将铅变成金子的想法。是的，基本上是这样，或者任何其他贱金属。这是一个愚蠢的想法，中世纪的人们痴迷于将铅或水银等贱金属变成金子，这在今天当然是荒谬的。
But there's this time when alchemists were these like really dope people backed by rich folks and powerful folks, including King Henry IV of France, a lot of Catholic monks practice alchemy, even Sir Isaac Newton was super into alchemy. He apparently wrote about it more than physics and optics. So for a long time hundreds and hundreds of years across the entire world, in the Middle East and Europe, there were these blurred lines between science and alchemy. In fact, alchemy can actually be traced back to the Arabic alchemy, which means chemistry, because apparently Egyptians were pretty big into alchemy back in the
但在那个时期，炼金术士是一群真正了不起的人，有富人和权贵的支持，包括法兰西国王亨利四世，许多天主教僧侣也练习炼金术，甚至艾萨克·牛顿爵士也超级迷恋炼金术。据说他关于炼金术的著作比物理学和光学还要多。因此，在很长一段时间里，长达数百年，在世界各地，在中东和欧洲，科学与炼金术之间的界限一直很模糊。事实上，炼金术实际上可以追溯到阿拉伯语的 “alkimiy-a”，意思是化学，因为显然古埃及人在当时非常热衷于炼金术，尤其是亚历山大港的希腊化时期，那是我以前住过的地方。所以向亚历山大港致敬。因此，炼金术曾经是一件非常大的事情，它在今天的流行文化中仍然非常普遍。我不知道你的孩子们是否玩《我的世界》或《魔兽世界》。根据粗略的谷歌搜索，我认为其中有一些炼金术士角色。我童年的一个例子是在《哈利·波特》中。整个第一本书都是关于魔法石的
day, especially during the Hellenistic times in Alexandria, which is where I used to live. So shout out to Alexandria. And so alchemy was this really big thing and it is still really prevalent in pop culture today. I don't know if your kids play Minecraft or Warcraft. Based on a cursory Google search, I think there are some Alchemist characters involved in those. And one of the examples for my childhood is in Harry Potter. The whole first book is about the sorcerer stone
或者在英国版本中，是哲学家之石，这就是那种能把金属变成金子，显然还能让人长生不老的的东西，这就是为什么伏地魔对它趋之若鹜。或者抱歉，那个不能说名字的人对它趋之若鹜。总之，这就是说，你可以用其他金属设计出金子的这种想法，在很长一段时间里，
or in the British version, the philosopher stone, which is this thing that turns metals into gold and also apparently makes people immortal, which is why Voldemort was all about it. Or sorry, he must not be named was all about it. Anyway, that's all to say that this idea that you could design, you know, kind of design gold from other metals was a
是一个巨大的伪科学追求。但当现代化学开始成为一门独立的学科时，这一切都随风而去了，你知道的，原子、中子、电子以及所有这些东西开始占据主导地位。好吧，讽刺的是，借助现代化学，实际上是有可能用其他元素创造出黄金的。这在自然界中确实会发生，比如当中子星碰撞时，如果你拥有核能力或像粒子加速器这样的设备，它也可以在实验室中发生，这就把我们带到了 20 世纪 60 年代的马里兰州。
really big pseudocyanthic quest for a really long time. But that all sort of went by the wayside when modern chemistry started to become its own discipline, you know, with atoms and neutrons and electrons and all that stuff sort of started taking hold. Well, the ironic thing is that with modern chemistry, it is actually possible to create gold from other elements. It actually happens in nature, like when neutron stars collide, and it can happen in labs, if you have nuclear capabilities or like a particle accelerator, which brings us to Maryland in the 1960s.
那里有一位名叫朱迪·滕佩利（Judith Temperly）的物理学家，她利用那里的核反应堆，成功地将水银变成了黄金。好吧，她实际上是将其嬗变了，这是一个专业术语，据我理解，这意味着她修改了一个元素的原子核，直到它拥有与黄金相同数量的质子。我要不要上一堂快速化学课？我的意思是，我可以奉陪。好的，酷。所以，快速化学课。元素是由其原子核中的质子数定义的。比如氢是元素周期表上的第一号，这意味着它的原子核中有一个质子。钠是第 11 号。它有 11 个质子，以此类推。所以这个想法是，如果你找到一个元素，其质子数量接近黄金，
There was a physicist there named Judith Temperly, and there with a nuclear reactor, she managed to turn Mercury into gold. Well, she actually transmuted it, which is a technical term, and as I understand it means she modified the nucleus of one element until it had the same amount of protons as gold. Should I do a quick chemistry lesson? I mean, I could go for it. Okay, cool. So quick chemistry lesson. Elements are defined by the number of protons in their nucleus. Like hydrogen is number one on the periodic table, which means it has one proton in its nucleus. Sodium is number 11. It has 11 protons, so on, so on. So the idea was that if you got an element that had close to the number of protons as gold,
那么也许利用粒子加速器，你可以向其中添加质子或剥离质子。但要做到这一点，你需要巨大的能量，因为如果你让两个带正电的东西（质子就是这样）碰撞，它们会互相弹开。所以你需要一个粒子加速器来做到这一点。而水银是元素周期表上的第 80 号元素。黄金是第 79 号。所以它们非常接近。所以她当时想，太好了，
then maybe with a particle accelerator, you could add protons to it or strip protons away. But to do that, you need a huge amount of energy because if you collide two positive things, which protons are, then they would bounce off each other. So you need a particle accelerator to do that. And Mercury is number 80 on the periodic table of elements. Gold is number 79. So they're very close. So she was like, okay, cool.
我把水银放进去，它有 80 个质子。我试着敲掉其中一个，也许其中一个质子会掉落，剩下的就是黄金了。完全正确。她真的这么做了。我想她成功地将一个原子转化成了黄金。你知道，这很棒。
I'll put Mercury in there, which has 80 protons. I'll try to smack one of those off, and maybe one of the protons will fall off and it'll be left with gold. Totally. And she did that. I think successfully converted one atom into gold. Which, you know, great.
这真的是一项了不起的工作。她证明了这个被疯狂痴迷了数百年的疯狂想法在科学上确实是可行的。然后到了 20 世纪 80 年代，一位名叫格伦·西博格（Glenn T. Seaborg）的教授，他是伯克利的诺贝尔奖得主化学家，制造了更多的黄金，用同样的方法将其嬗变化，只不过这一次他使用的是铋，你知道，与水银不同，铋是没有毒的。
That was really, really job. And she proved that this idea that was really crazy, but was so obsessed over for so many hundreds of years was actually scientifically possible. And then in the 1980s, this professor named Glen TCborg, who was a Nobel-winning chemist at Berkeley, made even more gold, transmitted it the same way, except this time he used Bismuth, which you know, unlike Mercury, isn't poisonous.
而且它在元素周期表上也很接近黄金。我记得它的质子数是 83 个。相比黄金的 79 个，它是第 83 号。所以他用粒子加速器将一些碳撞击到其中，并成功创造了数千个黄金原子。你知道，在这两种情况下，最终的结果在肉眼看来都是隐形的，
And it was also pretty close to gold on the periodic table. It was like, I think it was 83 protons. Number 83 compared to gold 79. So he smacked some carbon into it using a particle accelerator, and he managed to create several thousand atoms of gold. You know, in both cases, the end results were sort of invisible, like to the naked eye,
所以这似乎不是创造财富的最佳选择。完全正确。是的，尤其是考虑到你需要一个粒子加速器来做到这一点，我听说建造这个东西相当昂贵。所以这个延续了几个世纪的追求变得可行了，但最后，它非常不切实际，因为你确实需要花费比用铋创造一个金原子所能制出的黄金价值多得多的钱。
so it doesn't seem like the best option for creating wealth. Exactly. Yeah, especially considering that you need a particle accelerator to do it, which I hear is pretty expensive to build. So this century's long quest becomes possible, but in the end, it's pretty impractical because you really have to spend way more gold than could ever be made creating a gold atom out of business.
是的，是的。我想西博格化学家当时告诉美联社，为了用他在伯克利使用的方法创造出一盎司黄金，需要花费 1 千亿美元来创造一盎司黄金。我查了一下 quadrillion（千万亿）。它是一个后面有 15 个零的数字。与此同时，黄金的市价
Yeah, yeah. I think C. Bargit-Kemis told the Associated Press at the time that in order to create an ounce of gold using his process that he did in Berkeley, it would take $1 quadrillion to create an ounce of gold. And I had a look up quadrillion. It's a one with 15 zeros after it. And at the same time, the going rate for gold
大约是 560 美元，所以这并不是最具成本效益的方法，但我们做到了，这真的很酷。绝对的。非常感谢。是的。最后但同样重要的是 99 PI 军团中服役时间最长的士兵。埃弗里·特拉夫曼（Avery Truffleman）。我想先问你一个问题。你在湾区住了多久了？
was about $560, so not the most cost effective, but pretty cool that we did it. Absolutely. Thanks so much. Yeah. Last but certainly not least is the longest serving soldier in the 99 PI Army. Avery Truffleman. I want to start with a question for you. So how long have you lived in the Bay Area?
我是 1997 年搬到这里的。那么有什么旅游景点是你至今还没去过的？哦，对，让我想想。恶魔岛、39号码头、朗伯街。哦，对，我从来没开车走过朗伯街。真的吗？是的。太搞笑了吧，你会喜欢朗伯街。真的吗？是的。太搞笑了吧，你会喜欢朗伯街。
I moved here in 1997. So are there any tourist attractions that you still haven't been to? Oh, yeah, let me think. Alcatraz, Pier 39, Lumberth Street. Oh, yeah, I've never driven Lumberth Street. Really? Yeah. Yeah. That's so funny that you would love Lombard Street. Really? Yeah. Yeah. That's so funny that you would love Lombard Street.
好吧，没关系。我在纽约长大的，我的整个童年和成年期（或者说青少年时期）都在那里度过，我从来没有去过自由女神像的皇冠顶端。现在已经太迟了。这是那种每个人都一直让我去做的事。你知道的，这很典型，当地人对他们的城镇和城市的体验与游客有很大不同。因为总的来说，他们不会去看那些景点。
Well, it's okay. So I grew up in New York, lived there for my whole childhood and adulthood or youthhood, and I never ever went to the crown of the Statue of Liberty. And now it's too late. And it was the kind of thing that everyone always told me to do. And it's, you know, just kind of a typical thing that locals have a very different experience of their town and their city than visitors. Because by and large, they don't see the attractions.
我们的绝大多数游客都是外地来的，绝大多数。想想看，美国各地任何城镇的当地人都不会去进行游客活动。很多人根本不会去他们镇上的旅游景点。这是迪恩·德热里安（Dean DeGerian）。他是西雅图市中心一个叫先锋广场（Pioneer Square）的区域的导游。这里非常受游客欢迎。他为一家名为“比尔·斯派德尔地下之旅”（Bill Speidel's Underground Tour）的公司工作。顾名思义，这个旅游项目允许你走下几台阶，发现自己身处街道水平面以下。
The vast majority of our visitors are from out of town, overwhelming majority. Think about locals doing tourist activities in any town around the United States. Many people do not go to the tourist thing in their town. This is Dean DeGerian. He is a tour guide in an area of downtown Seattle called Pioneer Square. It's very touristy. And he works for a company called Bill Spidelles Underground Tour. And as the name suggests, the tour allows you to descend some steps and find yourself below street level.
字面意义上的地下。在地下。我在那里住了 12 年才知道这个地方。可以肯定地说，绝大多数在西雅图生活和工作的人根本不知道这一点。他们不知道。这就是我们环顾头顶上方的地方，你看到的所有那些人行道，
Like literally underground. Under the ground. I lived here for 12 years before I knew about it. Safe to say, easily, the majority of people who live and work in Seattle do not know this. They don't know. That is we look around up above there that all of the sidewalks you see up there,
所有那些人行道都是空的。他说的“人行道是空的”是什么意思？为了解释这一点，我们必须回到 1851 年西雅图建城的时候，当时第一批白人定居者抵达这里。在那时，这片土地的地形看起来完全不同。我的意思是，简直是天翻地覆。如果你看地图，西雅图曾经是一个小小的半岛，有时会涨水
all of those sidewalks are hollow. What does he mean that the sidewalks are hollow? To explain that, we have to go back to 1851 to the founding of Seattle when the first white settlers arrived. And back then, the land looked completely different, like topographically. It was, I mean, shockingly different. If you look at a map, Seattle was this tiny little peninsula that used to sometimes flood
周期性地变成一个小岛。这里并不是建立城市的最佳地点。但一些年轻的白人小伙子还是决定在这里建城。先锋广场很快就变成了一个挤满木制小房子和锯木厂的小伐木镇。那是最初的先锋广场地区，码头就在那里。一些早期的企业也在那里。
into an island periodically. And it was not the best place to establish a city. But some young white guys went ahead and established it. And Pioneer Square quickly became this little logging town full of tiny wooden houses and a logging mill. That was the original Pioneer Square area, and that's where the dock was. It's where some of the early businesses were.
这是历史学家艾伦·斯坦（Alan Stein）。他说，即使在定居之后，这个小镇有时仍然会发洪水。这意味着下水道系统是不可能的。厕所就在海平面上，所以问题是，每当涨潮时，水就会倒灌进来。所以，你可以想象，这些厕所喷涌出水来。这听起来太糟糕了。
This is historian Alan Stein. And he says, even after the settlement, the town would still flood sometimes. And this meant plumbing was impossible. The toilets were at sea level, so the problem is, anytime the tide came in, it would blast water through. And so, you know, these toilets erupting with water. Well, that just sounds awful.
哦，是的，把一个城镇建在这个地方真是个愚蠢的选择。这是一个糟糕的主意。但定居者决定咬牙切齿地忍受，他们忍受着他们的小城市的种种缺陷，只要他们能继续卖木材，直到他们不小心把整个城市烧成灰烬。当 89 年的大火袭来时，烧毁了……从先锋广场开始的那场大火烧毁了大部分那个区域，因为那时候，木结构建筑已经建得很高了。1889 年，大火袭击了西雅图，几乎将市中心夷为平地。
Oh, yeah, it was a stupid place to establish a town. It was a bad idea. But the settlers decided to grin and bear it and they put up with the many faults of their little city as long as they could continue to sell its lumber until they accidentally burned the entire city to the ground. And when the Great Fire hit in 89, that burned down, that started in Pioneer Square. That burned down most that area because by this time, wooden buildings had been built up. In 1889, the Great Fire hit Seattle, and it just pretty much levels downtown.
哦，是的，把城镇建在那里真是个愚蠢的主意。这真是一个糟糕的主意。但开拓者们决定硬着头皮忍受，他们尽可能地容忍他们小镇的种种缺点，只要他们能继续卖出木材，直到他们不小心把整个城市烧成平地。1889年大火来袭时，那场大火烧毁了许多地方，火灾是从先锋广场开始的。那烧毁了大部分区域，因为到这个时候，已经建起了很多木质建筑。在1889年，西雅图遭遇了大火，几乎把市中心夷为平地。
It's just destroyed. But miraculously, no one died in the Great Fire. So the city actually sees this as an opportunity. Seattle's like, okay, this is our big chance to get the town above sea level, and we can start again. They thought, well, let's grate it over. Let's pack up the streets so that they're 11 feet higher in the air. And that way it's a little more stable. But the business owner's already started building. The city didn't want to tell the businesses in Pioneer Square
完全被毁了。但奇迹般的是，在大火中没有人死亡。因此，这座城市实际上将此视为一个机会。西雅图觉得，好吧，这是我们把镇子提高到海平面以上的大好机会，我们可以重新开始。他们想，好吧，让我们把它垫高吧。让我们把街道填高，使其在空中高出11英尺。这样会更稳定一些。但是店主们已经开始建设了。市政府并不想告诉先锋广场的商家们
to wait until the project was done to rebuild. Because raising up the streets was this really ambitious project. It was going to take like 10 years to do. So you can't tell all the businesses in your town to take a 10-year hiatus. So the Pioneer Square businesses were asked that when they rebuilt, first they should do it in brick and stone, not wood, when they're lessened. And then secondly, they should add another entrance on their second floors. And slowly in increments, the city raised up the streets 5 to 11 feet up around the businesses. So they built their businesses with an entrance on the first floor and an entrance on basically the second story for the eventuality that the street
等到项目完成再重建。因为抬高街道是一个非常雄心勃勃的项目。这大约需要10年时间。所以你不能叫镇上所有的商家都停业10年。因此，先锋广场的商家被要求在重建时，首先应该用砖石而不是木头来建造，当他们减少时。其次，他们应该在二楼增加另一个入口。城市缓慢而分阶段地在商家周围将街道抬高了5到11英尺。因此，他们在建造企业时，一层有一个入口，基本上二层也有一个入口，以防街道
would raise to meet it. And there was a there was a while where the streets were raised up and then the sidewalk and the building were lower than the streets. So, for example, if you wanted to park your carriage in the street and then leave your carriage and go into a store, you had to actually go down, set the stairs or even ladders to get to these storefronts. Basically, the sidewalk at this point wasn't really joined to that second story, but the street was there, but the sidewalk wasn't there. Yeah, the sidewalk was still down at the old flood level.
最终会升高到与之一齐。有一段时间，街道被抬高了，然后人行道和建筑比街道还要低。例如，如果你想把马车停在街上，然后离开马车走进一家商店，你实际上必须走下去，踩着楼梯甚至梯子才能到达这些店面。基本上，此时的人行道并没有真正与二楼连通，但街道在那里，而人行道不在那里。是的，人行道还在原来的洪水水位。
Yeah, first level. It didn't all happen at once. It happened in increments, but yeah, and then the street was above it. So eventually, the city connected the raised streets to the new second story entrances with a new sidewalk. And so this covered up the old sidewalk and created this hollow space between the old sidewalk and the current one. Once the streets were graded and level, then businesses moved to the upper, the second story, and that's where their storefronts later became. So all these original storefronts were then covered over underground
是的，第一层。这一切并不是同时发生的。它是分阶段进行的，但是的，然后街道就在它上面。最终，城市用一条新的人行道将抬高的街道与新的二楼入口连接起来。这就覆盖了旧的人行道，并在旧人行道和现在的人行道之间创造了这个空心空间。一旦街道被平整，商家们就搬到了高处，即二楼，后来他们的店面就设在那里。因此，所有这些原本的店面随后都被覆盖在地下
And that's what became underground Seattle. So the underground was rumored to have a lot of different uses throughout its history People speculate about its life as speakeasies and gay clubs and paths for espionage or smuggling But honestly for most of its existence It was just abandoned or forgotten or used a storage space by the shops above it and pioneer square. But then in the 1960s, most of the businesses started to leave Pioneer Square and the area became kind of down and out. And so this was the 60s. Everyone was like, great, let's just tear down all the old buildings and pioneer square so we can build more space-agey stuff like the space needle. The space-age, the future, people were more looking forward than they were to the past. Except for a man named Bill Spidell.
这就是西雅图地下城的由来。传闻地下城在其历史上有许多不同的用途，人们猜测它曾被用作地下酒吧、同性恋俱乐部以及间谍或走私的通道。但老实说，在其存在的大部分时间里，它只是被废弃、遗忘，或者被上面先锋广场的商店用作储藏空间。但在20世纪60年代，大多数企业开始离开先锋广场，该地区变得有些破败。那是60年代。每个人都觉得，太棒了，让我们拆掉先锋广场的所有旧建筑，这样我们就可以建造更多像太空针塔那样具有太空时代感的建筑。太空时代，未来，人们更多地是展望未来而不是回顾过去。除了一个叫比尔·斯派德尔的人。
So Bill, he was a columnist for the Seattle Times, and he had an interest in history. A lot of it was because he had a lot of contacts. Like contacts with direct descendants of the founders of the city. Bill Spideyl knew people who were the sons or grandsons of the founding pioneer families because Seattle is a young history. As far as white settlement goes here in Seattle, really, it's just three generations away if you really think about it. And through these old timers, through stories, through rumors, Spideyl hears about these underground
所以比尔，他是《西雅图时报》的专栏作家，他对历史很感兴趣。很大一部分原因是他有很多联系人。比如与城市创始人的直系后裔有联系。比尔·斯派德尔认识那些建城先锋家族的儿子或孙子，因为西雅图的历史还很年轻。就这里的白人定居点而言，如果你仔细想想，其实也就隔了三代人。通过这些老一辈人，通过故事，通过传闻，斯派德尔听说了这些地下
kind of tunnels in downtown Seattle. And he eventually learns about the raising of the streets and these hollow spaces between the current sidewalk and the old sidewalk. And in 1965, Bill Spidell's underground tour was officially born. And he used the tours and opportunity to show Seattleites that they had a history. And they had a historic district that they were ignoring. And they thought they didn't. They thought they were this young city. This got the ball rolling on preserving Pioneer Square, and by 1969, it worked because it became a national historic district. And still is to this day.
西雅图市中心的某种隧道。他最终了解了抬高街道的事情，以及现在的人行道和旧人行道之间的这些空心空间。1965年，比尔·斯派德尔的地下之旅正式诞生。他利用这些旅行作为一个机会，向西雅图人展示他们有历史。他们有一个他们一直在忽视的历史街区。他们以为自己没有。他们以为自己是一座年轻的城市。这推动了保护先锋广场的进程，到1969年，它成功了，因为它成为了一个国家历史街区。直到今天依然如此。
Bill Spidell passed away in 1988, but today, if you go to Pioneer Square, you will see hordes of tourists roving around in groups of 47 taking Bill Spidell's underground tour. And they turn out these massive tours every day. 188 people come through every hour. And like one time I went, there was this woman like translating the tour in real time on her phone into Chinese. I mean, they're from all over the world.
比尔·斯派德尔于1988年去世，但今天，如果你去先锋广场，你会看到成群结队的游客以47人一组的规模四处游荡，参加比尔·斯派德尔的地下之旅。他们每天都接待如此庞大的旅行团。每小时有188人通过。有一次我去的时候，有个女人正在用手机把导游的讲解实时翻译成中文。我是说，他们来自世界各地。
And the tour very much continues in Bill Spidell's original style. It's a lot more dedicated to fun than facts. There are a lot of gags and dad jokes. They talk a lot about the exploding toilets and they tell tales about drunken debauchery on the raised streets. In the first year of construction alone, 17 men walked out of bars, tried to cross the street,
这次旅行在很大程度上延续了比尔·斯派德尔最初的风格。它比事实更致力于娱乐。有很多恶作剧和老爹笑话。他们谈论很多关于爆炸马桶的事情，并讲述在抬高的街道上酗酒放荡的故事。仅在建设的第一年，就有17个人走酒吧出来，试图过马路，
fell to their death stepping from the street to the sidewalk below. Bill Spidell said that it worked in a way because that was early Seattle's original one-step program. Oh, I love that joke. So it's a lot of unverified stuff and a few exaggerations, but honestly, that's true with a lot of touristy tours that kind of turn into this giant game of telephone. But in this case, without Spidelles, legends, and dad jokes, we might not have this part of town at all, or this piece of Seattle history that tourists know
从街道跌落到下方的人行道上摔死。比尔·斯派德尔说，这在某种程度上起作用了，因为那是早期西雅图最初的“一步到位”计划。哦，我很喜欢这个笑话。所以里面有很多未经证实的事情和一些夸张，但老实说，许多旅游团都是如此，它们有点像变成了一个巨大的传话游戏。但在这种情况下，如果没有斯派德尔的传说和老爹笑话，我们可能根本不会拥有这部分城镇，也不会拥有游客比当地人更了解的这段西雅图历史。
better than the locals. Since literally thousands of you asked, I'm going to tell you what I think of the redesigned Donald Trump presidential challenge coin. Right after this. You might not remember December 22nd, 2017 as a particularly notable day, but I will always remember it as the day the world first saw Donald Trump's redesigned presidential challenge coin. Now, if you were unfamiliar with challenge coins, please turn your himnals to episode number 156 of 9 MPI. It's called coin check, and you'll know everything you need to know.
正如成千上万的你们所问的那样，我将告诉你们我对重新设计的唐纳德·特朗普总统挑战币的看法。就在这之后。你可能不记得2017年12月22日是一个特别值得纪念的日子，但我永远会把它记作世界第一次看到唐纳德·特朗普重新设计的总统挑战币的日子。现在，如果你对挑战币不熟悉，请把你的赞美诗翻到99%不可见第156集。它叫硬币检查，你会了解你需要知道的一切。
But if you've been here a while, you know I know about challenge coins, and I care about them deeply. In fact, if you didn't serve in the military, there's a good chance you learned about challenge coins for the first time from 99% of visible. This show has its own challenge coins, so it's radio-topia. So my association with challenge coins is strong. And because of that, I was forwarded the December 22nd Washington Post article about Trump's garrishly over the top challenge coin by about 9,000 people. So on my other podcast, what Trump can teach us about Khan Law, we take the tweets of Donald Trump and we use them as a jumping off point to learn about the US Constitution.
但是如果你在这里待了一段时间，你就知道我了解挑战币，并且我深深地关心它们。事实上，如果你没有在军队服役，你很有可能是从99%可见第一次了解到挑战币。这个节目有它自己的挑战币，电台乌托邦也是。所以我对挑战币的感情很深。正因为如此，大约9000人把《华盛顿邮报》关于特朗普那个艳俗至极的挑战币的文章转发给了我。所以在我的另一个播客《特朗普能教我们什么宪法法》中，我们拿唐纳德·特朗普的推文作为切入点来了解美国宪法。
And if you haven't heard it, it's a really fun show. And it's not nearly as snorky and angry as you might think. Plus, my co-host on that show is a law professor and a friend of mine, her name is Elizabeth Jo, and she's super smart and just delightful to listen to. So check it out. One of the things we discuss a lot on the show is that Donald Trump has a tendency to subvert constitutional norms. And if you're into Trump,
如果你没听过，这是一个非常有趣的节目。它远没有你想象的那么尖酸刻薄和愤怒。另外，我在那个节目的联合主持人是一位法学教授也是我的朋友，她叫伊丽莎白·乔，她超级聪明，听她说话简直是一种享受。所以去看看吧。我们在节目中经常讨论的事情之一是唐纳德·特朗普有颠覆宪法规范的倾向。如果你喜欢特朗普，
you can actually appreciate that tendency. I know I totally dig people who push on rules to achieve the things I want them to achieve. Anyway, with the redesign of the presidential challenge coin, it's clear that Trump also likes to break the norms of taste, good design, and tradition. The new Trump challenge coin dispenses with the presidential seal and replaces it with a similar-looking eagle image, but the head of the eagle is pointed in the opposite direction for some reason, and it has Donald Trump's signature across the bottom.
你其实可以欣赏这种倾向。我知道我完全喜欢那些推动规则来实现我想实现的目标的人。无论如何，随着总统挑战币的重新设计，很明显特朗普也喜欢打破品味、良好设计和传统的规范。新的特朗普挑战币取消了总统徽章，取而代之的是一个外观相似的老鹰图像，但不知何故，老鹰的头部指向相反的方向，底部有唐纳德·特朗普的签名。
Instead of E. Purpose Unum, it says, make America great again. Then it says Donald Trump again on a ribbon that extends below the traditional circle of the coin. It is twice as thick as the most recent presidential challenge coins, and instead of the muted colors befitting a dignified office, this coin is gold, a very, very cheap looking gold. In terms of taste, I consider this new coin an impeachable offense. I will personally draw up the articles of impeachment myself, just give me a call. However, I also must consider this from a design perspective.
上面没有写“合众为一”，而是写着“让美国再次伟大”。然后在硬币传统圆圈下方延伸的缎带上再次写着唐纳德·特朗普。它的厚度是最近几位总统挑战币的两倍，而且这款硬币没有采用符合尊贵职位的柔和颜色，而是金色的，一种非常非常廉价的金色。从审美的角度来看，我认为这枚新硬币是一种可以遭到弹劾的罪行。我会亲自起草弹劾条款，只需给我打电话。然而，我也必须从设计的角度来考虑这一点。
And the key question in design is, does the thing do what it was designed to do? And in that sense, one could argue that the Donald Trump challenge coin is perfectly designed. It completely reflects the taste and style of Trump in his presidency in every way. It is in your face and untraditional. I find it unbelievably ugly and tacky and I don't like the ribbon protruding from the bottom of the circle, but it's fitting. Much like the man himself wears his wide shiny ties that calm down way too low. So just like I didn't
设计的关键问题是，这个东西做了它被设计要做的事情吗？从这个意义上说，可以说唐纳德·特朗普的挑战币是完美设计的。它在方方面面完全反映了特朗普及其总统任期的品味和风格。它张扬且不传统。我发现它丑得令人难以置信且俗气，我不喜欢从圆圈底部突出的缎带，但它很合身。就像这位男士本人总是系着垂得太低的宽亮领带一样。
really get the red mega hats, I can't argue that they weren't effective icons that did the job they were designed to do. So in a way, you kind of have to admire the new coin and judge it for what it is. And that is the limit to how far my generosity will extend because it is awful. It is really awful. It is awful to look at in every way. It is just, it is, it is, it is so bad. It's so bad. You heard it your first. 99% of visible is Avery Trollfman. Emmet Fitzgerald, Sharifusev, Delaney Hall, Teran Mazza, composer
真的搞不懂红色的MAGA帽子，我不能争辩说它们不是有效的图标，没有完成它们被设计来做的工作。所以在某种程度上，你不得不佩服这枚新硬币并根据它的本来面目来评判它。这就是我的慷慨所能达到的极限，因为它太糟糕了。真的很糟糕。从方方面面看都糟糕透顶。它简直是，它是，它是，它是太糟糕了。太糟糕了。你首先听到的是。99%可见是埃里·特罗夫曼。埃米特·菲茨杰拉德，谢里夫·尤瑟夫，德兰尼·霍尔，泰兰·马扎，作曲家
Sean Rial, senior producer Katie Mingle, digital director Kurt Colstead, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Night Foundation and sticker loving listeners, just like you. You can find 99% of visible and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
肖恩·里亚尔，高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔，数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特德，还有我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽奥克兰市中心的Radio Row制作。我们是来自PRX的Radio Topia的一部分，这是一个汇集了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的集体。我们得到了奈特基金会和像你一样热爱贴纸的听众的支持。你可以在Facebook上找到99%可见并加入关于节目的讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, where I'm Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But the real 99PI HQ is only at 99PI.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Twitter上@我 Roman Mars，也可以在@99PI org找到这个节目，我在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也一样。但真正的99PI总部只在99PI.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子来留下评论。